here we are another episode of our
series of internal software design
reviews this is hopefully the last stop
for our proof system for the next
version of often language and let's
start off looking at some graphic design
for proof objects I think so let's see
where are we at here so let's look at
what are we looking at here we're
looking at your yes so well can you
explain that
yeah I actually thought we're gonna open
the colors but first thing we're gonna
look at here is the summary boxes for
these this is my attempts if we have a
very very complex network like I'm
thinking okay that one looks nice you
shouldn't say graph it'll just say proof
object right yeah I was going off an
older source notebook that is so so
what's happening if the thing is really
complicated it's going to this but if it
isn't so complicated it's gonna give it
explicitly that seems kind of weird i I
don't understand it I don't think that's
something we should do because otherwise
how do you get to the explicit graph
okay I think here this was an
exploration of colors perhaps there is
another one with labels as well okay but
let's take a look at what's an example
here mm-hmm this this is I mean what we
have if we say find a question or proof
over here okay so this is the old style
I don't know what this is this is a
graph plot with its old Brown thing so
you're proposing a different thing with
colors for that do we have the code to
do that did you understand my question
okay so what is that is that intended to
be a graph object or at some output from
graph plot of what what is it how do we
get to that I am actually unsearched I
can be currently how
we are generating the current ionizes
because okay so Jonathan maybe you can
say what is this well in the
implementation now I have it's just a
graph that we're displaying in a summary
box so this will be the same thing
except that it's a graph with colored
colored nodes right right
so I don't think there's a problem with
that I think it's just using the same
graph rendering technology it just is
taking the color that's happening for
the I mean so here if you say this thing
and you say proof network if I'm not
mistaken then this would be that right
and you're suggesting using those colors
right here which seems completely
sensible to me yes I was I was just
wondering if we get past a certain level
of complexity these little summary boxes
get awfully dense and noodley I don't
know from an aesthetic standpoint okay
okay I mean it's a complicated thing and
let's show that it's complicated okay
well we typically do with summary boxes
is that when they get very complicated
the problem is that they might take very
long to to typeset so what we do is to
having some generic typically in gray
case and I mean if we think that's gonna
happen at some point well when do we
think that's gonna happen
above a hundred nodes or what and also
do we think that the right way to say
what's going on is is just I mean it's
not a graph it will say proof object
here right no you don't really want to
say vertex come what do we want to say
where did this come from the Vettes
count an edge count that doesn't seem
right that that came from an irrelevant
so what we're actually putting up is
this here is that correct so our plan we
were discussing this with died recently
he suggested that we have in the first
line logic and number of steps and in
the second one the theorem and then the
actions would be in the opened
version click in the plus why are we
giving logic I mean I guess
okay but then then are we giving it as
an actual English words equation of
space logic or what right now we are
using this a full string are you
proposing to combine those first two
lines that doesn't seem sensible this
seems like about the right size is there
a problem with this
it was complaining it's too large and
cases in which we have longer sets of
axioms this becomes quite large well I
don't think we should put the axioms
there I don't see any reason to do that
or alternatively similarly for the
theorem that could be quite long - I
would imagine you would have a you know
an alighted version of that only to a
certain like dot dot right that's how
it's not at the moment but it I had them
rather my suggestion that the axiom
should sort of be compressed within the
within the summary box and I accessible
with the plus no that's fine which is I
I haven't committed it yet because I'm
still playing around with it but that's
what I've been working on highly
sensible to me
okay okay so let's keep going back to
this design stuff so there's a there's a
detail of what colors are being used is
that correct mm-hmm and I believe in one
of them if I think it should have got
since along with the notebooks I have
two mock-ups going around larger views
of this with the colors that I have
specified in okay so this is this
creature mm-hmm it's I think if you zoom
out it'll give you a slightly more
bird's-eye view of it okay I think we
already said that we didn't we wanted
these dashes to be finer grained
dashes right right correct notes but I
will reflect the markup to do that okay
and this is fine I mean there's some
color palette here do we agree on what
the what the logic of this color palette
is why is this color palette the way it
is why is hypothesis and green wire
axioms in red and so on I don't see any
okay well didn't we discuss that last
time yes if I remember correctly the
conclusion from the meeting was that we
should have or at least one of the
suggestions was that the the nodes in
the in the graph should be shaped rather
than more in or an additional comment I
haven't heard back from Charles about
the possibility of doing that okay
perhaps in a first-generation college is
enough fine but but but we should be
able to get this is who's whose project
managing this nobody is I think she's
mad at some point but such more away
right now yes yes mm-hmm okay what she's
supposed to be project managing this and
and we should make sure that we get that
item actually done okay so if we think
that we've got okay last time we talked
about you're right
having shapes for these do we need to
shall we just get Charles right now and
ask him whether that's possible
I thought last time we had he'd said
that some simple shapes are possible
memory as well yeah okay so we need to
know what those shapes should be
that we come up with a list of what
those shapes should be other than the
axioms being sort of triangular arrow
type things and the conclusion being a
sort of tombstone marker I don't think
we came up with any but I think that I
think that's sufficient if we keep
everything else the same and just change
the D I agree the shapes of those two
but what about hypotheses
you
it'll be nice if the shape of the
hypothesis is similar to the shape of
the axioms I agree now in terms of the
colors I just have no idea what this
color scheme is supposed to be about
right now it's completely arbitrary I
mean it should be something that makes
some sense so by the way we've got a
bunch of background noise here so these
are all the types axiom critical pair
lemma substitution lemma hypothesis
conclusion is that correct correct yep
okay
so
you know if there is a flow from how do
we want to represent the sort of
arbitrariness of the initial axioms and
hypothesis could whoever is producing
that background noise please try to
figure that out and mute themselves
okay
so and
I mean I would have thought for these
intermediate things using yellow and
orange is probably okay I don't know why
but but and having color values that are
fairly similar for the substitutional
Amazon the critical Pearl honors does
that make sense
I certainly think so given that they are
in sometimes the least important things
when you're first looking at the network
right so they should be in some probably
yellowish color that's okay so then I
don't understand why axioms should be
read and hypotheses should be green that
doesn't make any sense to me now that
what all the clothes are the stats is
that I agree with that I would want them
much more of a similar color value
because they are first-order yes I agree
with that they should be much more
similar in values okay well so what are
we gonna pick for the you know what is
the axiom color versus the conclusion
color do we have any kind of you know
what would we do if we were representing
something whether it's a beginning you
know of a race on the end of a race what
would we color those two different
things if there is any kind of you know
analogy there I think the analogy would
I think there's something wrong with
your audio oh I apologize let me see if
I can fix that
hello
okay then we got a bunch of other stuff
we have to cover here so let's let's um
so we are also doing this documentation
and it's knitting is that correct that's
the other thing we're trying to do here
did we did we finish on the guys are you
still there yep
did we finish on what the the proof
structure is supposed to look like yes
the proof of step seaming yes yes so
they said now a more compact version it
looks and look like okay do we have Kris
back or not
I think he's hello Kris
by the way this bug that these things
are staying blue even when they're
defined it's still with us do I need to
send mail about it or can somebody else
take care of this I reported it like a
week ago okay why are we listening to
typing in our ears Kris is back with us
okay Kris are you here hope yes
hopefully my audio is better now it is
better yes okay so do you have an answer
for what we were just discussing for the
colors for the color start and end yes
way of coloring something which is the
start of something versus something
which is the end of something I think it
makes sense to me to have something a
little bit more akin to stop ways I can
get the start of the thing it should be
green terminal
things should be red and we do a orange
and yellow blend for intermediate things
to go through all the sort of like a
racetrack style set of colors
interesting idea
with with green at the end oh I think
greed to begin with red is our
conclusion okay
um
wondering whether they yeah I don't
particularly useful okay fine
that that sounds okay I think it might
not be wanting to be I mean maybe it's
more of a teal color at the beginning so
it doesn't look like or we can have the
axioms in one color and the hypothesis
in a different color
mm-hmm i I've got a that's part of
another project I've been working with
color data 97 to have a universal scheme
for alpha graphics I can think of two
nice sort of tila greens that I could
have why don't you see if you can
construct this and the next few minutes
let us know and let's we'll go on with
some other stuff and then hope certainly
food the whole thing in this meeting um
okay so let's take a look at this is
this this is as we discussed and
designed it last time is that right I
believe so good um okay all right so in
the examples that we have here okay so
then you've also got what is the way of
getting we're not calling it human
readable are we didn't we have a
difference yes sorry I the version that
you're using because I was still working
on a bunch of things I haven't actually
committed it to the X kernel yet but in
the version I'm currently working on
it's it's called proof notebook which
was one of the suggestions from the
meeting okay fine is that reflected in
the documentation and not yet but it
will be okay well this doesn't have any
okay so the property should go in the
other in improve improve objective okay
okay can we reduce the trees in the
axioms then find equation or proof um is
that really the right way to say it I
mean it isn't it you know this kind of
denies undecidability if I might say so
you see what I'm saying I mean does it
guarantee to find it know the use of
otherwise is probably wrong okay so then
if it review if it can be reduced to
yield first that works on a failure find
a proof of the equation of logic theorem
th am using the axioms this okay if the
earth if if find equational proof
succeeds in reducing theorem to true it
doesn't need to say that because it's
obvious then then it returns a proof
object right by direct then if it's
seeds in reducing the theorem to false
it returns a failure object right
correct
succeed in reducing
okay okay do we need to make a comment
about the case where it doesn't can't do
it
that's commented upon later with the
time constraint parameter because it's
abstract parameter sorry I don't know
probably an option it's in the options
section but where is it in the
documentation up here in the options
section I think but but it that's just
an example it needs to be yeah so what
are the options for this function that's
the only option okay that by the way is
miss type set somebody should fix it the
dot dot is not correct typesetting there
I don't want to fix that right now make
sense Jose yes we were out that yeah
sure okay this is also not correctly
typeset and the expo one should be a
first subscript etcetera etcetera right
yes yes really this could have multiple
theorems here and multiple so this is
not really um this is miss type set to
something I was using the example of
reduce or full simplify where lists can
be specified but there are new they're
only given as one parameter okay what
are the functions should be referenced
here prove object reduce what else
should be reference
instance okay yeah I was thinking that
ideally when we can show Falls we would
return some sort of counter example but
unfortunately while Meister is not
giving it okay
first a second um okay Chris has some
updated colors here let's try looking
now it's quite nice it seems a little
bit more logical the other thing that
bothers me a little bit about this is
that yellow really does stand out and I
don't think there's that what we want
I would probably um I would probably
reverse them in that case no no no
decent we don't want to stand out either
these are these are very similar we
don't want to stand out more than the
other things in here I would make these
values you know I would make that yellow
thing darker so it doesn't pop out that
makes sense yes indeed I can do that
okay great and those those lines look a
lot better mm-hmm I think so as well
do you know what do you know the spec to
give to Jonathan so you can put that
into the graph code in Wolfram language
- line Styles I'm unsure I'll give him
the illustrator sort of reference specs
and
fine fine fine find equational proof has
following option
so this is now time constraint default
value infinity how much time to allow
for - to allow and finding it in how
much time to allow so now what happens
if it if it what what does it do if it
runs out of time constraint it returns a
failure object with some kind of
specification that said it was a time
constraint failure or what yep this is
there two kinds of failures either the
theorem is false or a ran out of time
okay
um
if find equational proof exceeds a
specified that exceeds as any the
specified time constraint it returns a
failure object okay okay let's go look
at proof object then we can make this an
actual live page I'm thinking simplify
her stand constraint 300 seconds I think
this should have infinity a few because
it simplifies used as part of other
computations I see yeah that's good by
the way the thing that this should
reference first is full simplify before
again reduce right is it correct for it
to reference reduce I think so some of
the format of the sum function is based
on Reeves okay so we're in that list
should we put find equational proof
arguably at the end it's really kind of
a different thing okay now proof object
eventually will support all the types of
logic but right now it's only question
on logic that's why we put it there why
aren't we just showing an opaque thing
for the actual innards of the proof
object analogous to what we do let's say
it's a socket connection object as an
obscure example except I'm moving wrong
but it exists just something where we
have an opaque object yeah that's what
we do I don't think we should give the
explicit contents here I don't think
it's particularly useful okay what if we
so in the future if we allow more
general kinds of logics beyond
equational do we not want to have
different summaries for of course
because we do but but we're not
documenting what the innards of a proof
object are you just access I mean um
and by the way this possible properties
should include logic logic sorry yes it
does I have is it that the documentation
on that yet okay so shall I add that in
here so in those properties are from one
build ago okay all right okay
so let's go here so let's say proof
object and the obscured are key tools
mechanisms will show you this represents
a proof object generated by find
equation or proof
okay properties of an equation of a
proof some mentally equation of logic
proof of proof can be obtained using
possible properties include okay okay um
so here we would want to say logic type
alright logic what's that
proof logic perhaps better idea yes is
it really a proof logic that I mean it's
the logic is a feature of the theorem
the axioms and the proof okay so what i
would argue logically nia logic might be
sort of a conclusion i mean what is it
usually called it's usually called gosh
i should remember this um you know when
people say they're using ZFC or they're
using some other you know what i'm
saying they're using some foundation
yeah foundation is the usual term
axiomatic basis or something basis logic
I mean I don't we just call it axiomatic
basis I'm yeah yeah exactly
it's not quite like all your hair so
what should we call it
it means what it refers to this is one
value right now which is equation of
logic but in the future presumably when
we have other things that will refer to
something different
I think logic is perfectly fit because
you mean the way these things are
specified as you say sort of
intuitionistic logic or the equation of
logic or first-order logic or whatever
it is
I think logic is the right term so what
are we gonna call an equation of logic
like that we're just equational I would
say question or logic and then we could
have fair enough
model logic or first-order logic okay
all right proof object what else are we
going to have here we might refer to
layered graph plots it's that relevant
or layered what is it called now just
layered graph still there you've got
blood is that worth referring to here
well we're no longer using it at least
I'm not in the version I'm currently
working on we're using the whatever it
is graph layout layered or digraph
layered okay so we'd refer to graph here
and a proof object what else should be
referred to under proof object
data set possibly yeah seems obscure
um
what about the output of Verdi
which is something a little bit like
this Michael what do you think
no storm pinion I personally like it use
just as a function as your friend type
thing yeah yeah better then safe route
75 or something yes you have more
control over things okay all right okay
so we've got these okay so we now we've
got to knit these things but more to the
point what happened Jonathan to your
repository data repository and Trey
about theorems and proofs about sorry
axioms and theorems right so I mean we
we went through a few ideas at the last
meeting I think the one that we settled
on at least for the time being if I
remember correctly was it was to have
something like the old equational theory
function the experimental equational
theory function that I made which I can
show off quickly now if you want please
and go ahead me screen so the essential
idea was we have something like a quit
you'd be able to say equational theory
basic logic and it would give you give
you a list of axioms which you could
then put into an equation of proof using
formal symbols and then you'd have an
association which would allow you to
parameterize each of the operators so if
you want to specify the and operators
given by a you can do that so you want
to change the or operator or something
and this just seemed to me to be a
better and more flexible way of
representing these axiom systems than
having a data set with an association
which you couldn't parameterize right
but so where do these things come from
so these come from some resource some
ultimately a repository of theories but
what about the theorems themselves we
could have an association that contains
the axiom system and a list of notable
theorems
okay so just those have to be sort of in
correspondence because if you're
changing the names of the operators you
better be able to change that in the
theorems as well right exactly yeah so
what's our idea for that
I mean we could say equational theory
basic logic but then your qualifying
that basic logic thing but then there
are certain properties that you get so
for example one possibility would be to
say equational theory and then that
first argument is both basic logic and
potentially a sort of qualifying
Association and then the second argument
is a property and that property could be
the default property would be axioms
mm-hmm by the way I mean given a
particular theory an equation or theory
does one consider an equation of theory
to be defined by its axioms or can there
be multiple axioms for a given theory
was the theory typically is that the
whole set of all actions and theorems so
right but for example Huntington logic
and basic logic I mean and then you know
like my axiom system for boolean algebra
does that get is is that its own so I'm
using this the same scheme that was used
in nks where these are treated as
separate axiomatic systems yes they are
equivalent and fine equational proof if
given enough time can actually prove
their equivalents but I think it's I
think it's useful to treat them the
separate system because they do have
they are of the axioms they use are
quite radically different but so when
you say a theory your concept is a
theory is defined by its axioms not
defined by its in a sense I mean
ultimately in some I mean of course this
is an awkward business because there
might be two theories that are
equivalent but we don't know it right as
was the case with Robins logic for a
long time and um but so there isn't one
of these things that's called boolean
algebra well that is basic logic again
I'm using the naming convention for
inferring KS okay well that's fine but
but then but that is the okay but basic
logic is boolean algebra with some
particular axiom system right okay what
would the standard
boolean algebra accent I mean there's
random ones in different books okay I
mean you might it probably claims in and
guess that there is a sort of standard
one but it's kind of floppy right
whatever it is that's the one I mean is
it okay um this is pretty nice
okay so the question is then if we do
this we could initially just define a
bunch of built in things in equational
for equational theory but then
ultimately we would have somewhat
obscurely
a repository of theories so Michael how
does this relate to I mean do we imagine
I mean as we have other things in
equational logic would we have the same
repository or different repositories and
how does that relate to the things that
you know axiom systems that are
available and let's say lean and so on I
do not know event I mean in a Lynda's
basically only one axiom system really
there that constructive logic does no
choice in any form okay which basically
supersedes this one that's why there is
no problem okay but constructive logic
is the equivalent of equational logic
here it's not so much the set of axioms
right you can still specify premises um
the ponding means that they have a
library large library that a user's
basis so but but they can they can still
load various bits of them so I don't
quite understand then I'll share here so
I mean we believe that what we need here
ok so there's an equation or Theory
thing here and that equational theory
could be an equation or theory
associated but let's say you know the
the I don't know the join append and
sort of fragment of symbolic transfer
nations so in other words we could have
a bunch of theorems that say you know
their pen append and prepend commute
with each other and things like this am
i right which will be set up in this way
and that would then be in this world
this would that would be equational
theory of you know I don't know what we
want to call it you know list operations
or something no that's quite the right
right and then now by the way what
happens if we use actual Wolfram
language Ann's and ORS does it get all
snarl up yes and that's that will not
work I mean the the actual equational
theory will will work but if we try to
parse it instead and if we try and prove
something from this why won't that work
there may be pre evaluations that spoil
well yeah my question is okay so the the
point about equational proof is that we
are assuming property lists we're
assuming these binary operators have no
properties whereas and what you were
doing when you said there are multiple
axioms or multiple theorems you're using
the actual built-in and operator that is
somehow outside of the equation all
outside the equation or proof system is
that correct yes right you said when you
when you specify axioms you specify
theorems the operators have to be
symbols that we can then manipulate they
can't they can't be predefined
fulfillment functions say that in the
documentation by the way and that should
be impossible issues and the examples
sure okay
are we gonna try to introduce I mean
this without this equational theory
thing I have to say it's pretty hard to
use there's some this find equational
proof business and I feel like you know
this seems perfectly reasonable why
don't we just introduce it there's any
problem with that I mean can we can we
get this in you've already got punished
definitions there is that correct well I
I will be a bit concerned of having this
symbol as system we'll have it in some
experimental well I mean it'll be an
experimental system simple why you
concerned because it's the same thing
that we did before changing a question
I'll prove object to a proof object we
try to generalize so here eventually we
should have a marginal object that takes
a logic and then what when we call
axiomatic theory in is this is this a
data function that will then interact
with entities and things in that perhaps
I would think so I would think so I
would think that this is very much like
I mean I I would say it more like net
model right with a neuron that's where
you can have where it's basically just a
shortcut for getting things from
repository by making sense doesn't it
model have this parameterization feature
which parameterization feature you know
the idea the equivalent to being able to
rewrite the and and or operators no I
can't think of any nice way of getting
this to query repository and then
parameterize some of the symbols but
maybe there is wait wait wait wait wait
so what you're saying is look in the
repository and that's why not all
repositories are the same they require
in the repository there will be a raw
version of that first expression with
default choices for the symbols what are
the default choices and all not okay
what are those are those system are
those symbols in the global context or
what no they're strings at present I
can't think of
any better way to avoid generating
symbols in global Michael do you have an
idea here I mean they could be entities
I suppose that's that's what you had
suggested recently which which everybody
has talked to a farm thinks it's a
pretty okay idea but if I wanted to have
a sec meeting about it okay what
summarize what the rough idea is the
last idea was that we would have
entities for for things that right now
we like generically to be heads and we
inactivate this entities and the
inactivate entity types at smallest like
a symbol also then the yellow book so
that it becomes nice and taut readable
but that's what we were talking about
for like mathematical constants he said
it functions mostly because we would use
it heads yeah okay fine yeah okay but
but these ones are much more arbitrary
these ones just come with you know these
are just random binary operator often
interpreted as and
Randleman kinda cannot be an entity like
an entity has a certain well-defined set
of features that you find it I
understand that so that's the point I
mean that's the thing that is bizarre
about axiomatic theories is that you
know ultimately um you know in in this
was the kind of a hundred years ago kind
of notion right that that these things
oh it's just a binary operator it's just
a unary operator and that's all you have
to say about it the fact that we
interpret it as and or or is kind of a
separate layer so the question but but
clearly for this we need to name you
know this is a thing you know this is a
thing conventionally known as and write
it it's just a binary operator binary
operator number two in this axiomatic
system but it is conventionally known as
and and we want to have this or that
mapping I mean the fact is look if you
look in a you know one of the kind of
hundred years ago books of mathematical
logic you will find it says you know a
theory is defined by certain operators
and you know these variables it probably
doesn't talk about although it will say
you know we have the following
essentially dummy variables by making
sense yep um and so what that's
basically saying is that sort of
qualifying um the you know in a sense
there's a manifest that says in this
instance of this equation all of this
axiomatic theory we are going to as the
binary operators we're going to have
things called
a B and Q or something and as that this
we're going to have it as that and so on
so in a sense what I would expect the
original sort of object to have a bunch
of lists or associations that basically
named yeah I mean we're it's going to
have a list of binary operators a list
of unary operators a list of operators
molls basically as part of the original
axiomatic theory there will be a list of
operator symbols and then what you're
doing is you're saying you can translate
that list of operators symbols into a
different list now the question is in
the original list of operator symbols
arguably in this notation they should
just be formal symbols for example we
could have them be I don't know in the F
range or something you know we could
have them be capital letter formal
symbols we have those don't we yep I'm
happy to do that I mean does that
Michael what do you think about that
it's going to be said I would think what
that that's good not bad huh it's good
to be so difficult to read oh yeah it's
gonna be absolutely horrendous to read
but the whole point is that if the raw
form of these things is that then what
we can do is to map that into for
example we can conventionally map it
into something else yes but with the
strings it's very easy to map and into
some other end while remembering that
capital F means and in capital G I
understand that I understand but but so
the question is what is the underlying
representation for and my point is that
we should be using symbols
maybe I mean these are formal symbols
that don't mean a thing but it could
easily be that the initial okay the
question is what what does it when we're
naming it and what is that thing that's
named and because in other cases even
the variables could have conventional
names for example for example let's
consider the identity and a group theory
anyway right now I think it's with IIIi
was using the letter E and in this
version it doesn't it's not represented
at all but but so so what wait a minute
what is that that is a that's like a
constant
thing not a variable right that's not a
okay so then we have another so what is
the collection and this is sort of
standard mathematical logic what is the
collection of things there's operators
there's dummy variables and there's some
kind of constants is that right right
and the only difference between the
dummy variables and the constants is
that one set is quantified over and the
other one isn't
okay but so similarly then what we're
saying is that the identity element
right just like the ands and ORS and so
on the identity element is another thing
that has a special interpretation and it
conventionally has a special name my
claim is that there is a roar underlying
representation that is completely
obscure because it has completely non
okay so here's the thing you're
prejudicing it by saying what's and and
what's or because the fact is most of
these axiom systems you can switch those
around right so you know and and the
very claim I mean it take piano
arithmetic for example you know the fact
that we write multiplication with a time
sign in Purana arithmetic is completely
conclusory in a sense that the truth of
the situation is the axioms of pianura
arithmetic don't at all imply that that
binary operator is what we think of as
multiplication because p on arithmetic
also allows non-standard arithmetic for
which that quotes multiplication
operator is some totally exotic thing
that we might you know that that there's
no reason to think we should represent
by a time sign or something it isn't it
isn't the multiplication that we think
of it isn't the multiplication that in
Wolfram language would be represented by
the function times right I understand
but is there not also an argument to be
made that if you just if you just return
by default some list of formal symbols
as your operators that are totally
obscure yes yes it's don't we want some
kind of indication that says you know
that this isn't multiplication but this
is what is conventionally known as
multiplication in the context of piano
arithmetic or something like that
okay so an alternative okay so let me
let me try another alternative so for
the function symbols and the constants
is we could have a wrapper and we could
have the string inside
so we could have a rapper that's called
something like I mean just write it down
something like formal function of quotes
and now you know the fact is we can
typeset that in all kinds of different
ways
I like that that's a good well Michael
woody do you have a so then what we
would do is make a pretty different
meaning of former then we use it for the
former symbols why
because there we tried to escape the
context issue and changing issues which
already somehow is solved with the pure
steam end but on you also sitting in the
formal symbol you're also saying that
this is a symbol which can't be written
to which is the same as what we're
saying with a formal function notice I'm
saying that's the same or devastating
end you can try to deform right to this
thing and so what you added sugar right
okay yes what's the women so what are
you saying so you're saying this this is
a yet more formal because it doesn't
even mean know what women what one other
feature of a formal symbol is it has no
well-defined meaning it is a thing which
can't have a value assigned to it it
doesn't have a meaning associated with
it but there's I feel like okay what's a
explain cut what would you call them
what would you call this one I mean we
could be very obscure we could call it
axiomatic theory function that seems
extremely obscure
so it's write down the other case so the
other case is formal symbol yeah I was
going to mention that because we should
I have to mention but well I like it
conceptually I feel like it's confusing
because it isn't the simple formal
constant but it works if you call
something simpler than you test if it's
a simple and says no that's confusing
well fair enough and in some sense that
the function name is also a symbol in
the in the formal logic sense but okay
so let's imagine it was these things
then what would happen is in the
axiomatic theory what we would have is a
collection so if we write down in the
axiomatic theory we would have an
association and the thing would have one
of the pieces of the Association will be
quotes formal functions arrow and then a
list of formal functions and then from a
constants and then we would have axioms
which are given in terms of those formal
whatever's and that's probably what we
would have and those axioms ok so then
when we use the thing axioms is returned
by default that's correct but axioms
with the formal functions and formal
constants which will be typeset in a
nice way but underneath it would say
formal function blah blah blah but then
what we would do is we would allow you
to say let's say the formal functions
were and and or we would allow you to
say you know somewhere we will allow you
in when you call axiomatic theory to say
so let's just write this down I assume
attic theory let's say group theory up
and then you'd say
yeah possibly in that argument yes um
then you like multiplication arrow
Center dot the symbol Center dot and you
know then you would say comma identity
quotes identity arrow whatever it is II
that that's a little bit more or less
like lien would do it yeah to do what -
to basically say how do you want a
certain operation to format mm-hmm okay
it doesn't mean that we need to add
maybe this isn't a problem but don't
wouldn't we need some kind of
consistency check on the axiomatic
theory think it's produced because now
the formal functions the formal
constants the axioms aren't independent
[Music]
well there's another problem which is
the theorems that you're okay so the
other question is I mean so then we
could have notable theorems and the
issue there is in the axiomatic theory
thing up there we need to have some
properties then so I mean I don't know
whether we package we want a package
that would only be for some finite
amount of predefined stuff
yes but I think what my point is that
group theory with the what we need is
some kind of you know we keep on
kneading this something where you know
we're typically using rules to represent
this group theory arrow whatever to
represent the sub casing of group theory
with that multiplication operation and
so on so then we can have the second
argument of axiomatic theory be the
property and that second argument would
be notable theorems or it would be by
default axiom but we could use a list in
the first argument which is list and
group theory and then comma rules or
Association probably reasonable that's
probably better more consistent it's you
know it's an operator that we keep on
kneading this up casing operator of some
kind
um but wise isn't this enough and and I
mean so we don't need their from our
functions etc so a chromatic theory
already would return with center dot
excellent well but what if you don't
give that what if you what if you don't
give that second element that we could
give instead multiplication did a string
that we justified we don't worry I was
trying to avoid doing that because I
don't want to have strings as as heads
yeah but what I see is that now we are
just wrapping the string stings are
still there we're just wrapping them I
know but for some reason I think that's
going to be better
I just think having strings as heads
it's just a it's just sort of it it's a
it's a path we've not gone down and it
seems weird to go down it for this where
after all I mean
we wrap it with for function and formal
constant we get to typeset in all kinds
of ways and so on I mean we might even
truth is if we typeset it as an infix
operator it would look a lot better
which we certainly could do but I feel
like if we basically have this automatic
theory and we have the first element of
the first element probably a fine at
least I assume and not freely treatable
because what would it do then I feel
like we need a polka Matic way to access
the possible left-hand side of the
second element okay fine
so the answer to that is it's axiomatic
theory of group theory that first thing
, and then it would be exactly the thing
formal functions here instance right so
if you got no no what are you doing
leave that leave that Jonathan leave
that leave that we were all good there
on the line above say comma formal front
comma quotes formal functions and that
would then return no no we're told to do
how do I know in some bizarre theory
that I don't know what what can i or do
I have to say right okay sorry I
understand yeah yeah so let's call it
formal parameters we could have a common
combined thing called formal parameters
and that gives you that list of
left-hand sides of keys that you have to
give in that Association
yes a multiplication identity an inverse
right and now what we could do is we
could say formal parameter we could have
another second element which is called
formal parameter rules okay don't change
that one copy it copy it down um formal
parameter rules and what that returns
just as a convenience is that
Association saying multiplication string
multiplication goes to formal function
of quotes multiplication so in other
words it gives you defaults there right
so it's giving you the defaults and the
ones you want to change
you can change to whatever you want you
can either change them to other formal
functions or you can change them to you
know sent a dot or something now
ultimately the way this would work
presumably is that each one of these
things would get its own essentially
documentation page because it would
actually be in a repository so the fact
that these might be built in initially
might be a small number of built in
theories ultimately there will be a
repository that initially would contain
probably 20 of these things and then in
principle people could add things to
that repository and in principle
somebody could add I mean just like you
know I've got that listing and kso just
random axiom systems right somebody I
mean sort of interesting I mean somebody
gonna add a random axiom system but
they've got to put a description in
there and it's like this is random axiom
system 123 we don't know what it's good
for is a somewhat unconvincing
description I mean this or of course
bakes for extensions like I have coops
here we are now going to add a second
finally operation to it right then
that's then exactly that's fine then
what you do then okay then then there's
no reason why you can't refer to the
group theory in you know when you build
out another repository entry for another
axiomatic theory refer to group theory
because you know it's already in the
repository and the repository has the
feature that once you know once it's in
there it's not coming out of that so you
can permanently refer to it
now I mean the thing that is slightly
bizarre and interesting is this point
that you know there's an infinite
collection of possible axiomatic
theories only some subset not well
understood what it is do we care about
in mathematics and that sort of laid
quite bare by saying there's this
repository and you're putting just
putting into it the interesting
axiomatic theories as opposed to the
arbitrarily constructed ones
I mean I think this is pretty reasonable
I don't know Jose Jonathan Michael
comments is anybody was James here also
is I think so if he's here yes yes I'm
here have you been playing attention and
if so do you have any comments on this I
generally think it's a pretty good idea
and I am particularly interested to see
how how extensions might work all right
I like the axiomatic theory part I'm not
sure about the formal part in particular
this distinction between functions and
constants can we have just a formal
thing that a formal construct we could
call it we should probably discuss it
with all everything right I mean I think
they're in lean they tend to refer to
all of those as constants I see it I
mean it's unfortunately it is similar to
the things that we have you know we have
this notion of external objects for
other purposes like referring to random
things and more Delica for system
modeler
but I think that's a little different I
mean this thing look this thing I mean
it has it has a hundred and thirty years
or something of somewhat mottled history
of what on earth are these things
because you know this is this is the
horror of they have a name but the name
doesn't mean anything it's a you know
it's a class of things which are you
know these are these are more formal
well I mean they're not that unlike the
symbols in our language which also could
mean anything
yes but our language is symbolic so I've
introduced something which is called
symbolic or formal since oh it's more
formal but in what sense okay can we
describe sort of philosophically why is
this more formal than what we already
have or isn't it oh it's what's the
difference between the the symbol F in
our language and a formal construct I
think the answer is because these are
dummy objects
the only thing that matters is that they
are consistent they're scoped
effectively that the only thing that
matters is that when you call it F when
you call the binary operator F in some
theory you better call the binary
operator and the theorems you're trying
to work on in that theory also F but the
actual name F never has significance
whereas in our language when you have a
you know a thing called foo or something
that actual you know that I guess the
point is that in our language that name
foo is supposed to have I mean it can
have a meaning attached to it yes it can
have an explicit meaning attached to it
by giving by being assigned values and
so on we're in this setting the thing
has is merely a placeholder because it
could never have values associated with
it well it has implicit constraints that
are set by the axioms rather than an
explicit value I think that's the key
difference the main difference would be
there's no notion of evaluation normally
in this series right right I mean
honestly our symbols insofar as we're a
sort of pure functional language
obviously our symbols play the same role
they're merely you know they could be
there they're there they're merely
things holders of structure not holders
of I mean but look the question of how
they hold meaning one way to hold
meaning is to have a value that is found
by evaluation though whether way to hold
meaning is by your relationship to other
things which is kind of what's happening
here is we're defining these constraints
which define the relationship of
different different constructs well we
need a name for this
I mean it's some what should we start
off calling it I mean the the possible
names are formal symbol which seems kind
of silly
formal constant which seems you know the
other thing we could call it is what
about axiomatic constant or axiomatic
symbol for that matter but axiomatic
constant seems better and why don't you
like form oh just for me because I'm
worried about using that up here I mean
maybe that's a a future I mean this is
the thing is okay the question is how
much do we really believe in
mathematical logic in some sense because
this is I mean you know my own feeling
is that there's some significant
evolution that's happening I mean look
if you look at the history of this field
right it was you know people in the in
the time of Frei Garin piano and all
those guys you know had we're trying to
abstract away from the particulars of
you know plus and times and all kind of
thing they just said let's put in these
formal symbols of some kind but somehow
oh I don't know somehow with this
rebirth of proof assistants and all that
kind of thing I kind of think we have
not reached the end of of kind of the
ways things what we represent in
particular as we start getting programs
represented in this formal way and so on
did that make any sense probably not I
mean my point is okay we are we are only
in the very early stages of programs
being represented formally I have no
idea how we're going to take our
language and starts I mean so in other
words given our language right things
like prepend and append are at some
level symbols that are direct carriers
of meaning but they're also at some
level things that could be the subject
of theorems and they're making sense um
and so I understand the relationship
between that and I can imagine that
we're going to want a version just like
we were playing around with it in
activation and so on as a way to be able
to manipulate code I think we're in the
early phases okay that the difficulty is
prepend an append are directly given
meaning in our language just like and
and or were conventionally given meaning
in boolean algebra you know in in logic
before people came along and said never
let's abstract it away and just call
them arbitrary binary operators but
we're still at the stage where we
imagine that there is a ground truth
meaning or something to things like
prepend and append it feels like what
we're doing here is we're trying to
abstract away from the ground truth
meaning and I don't quite understand how
that works for different did this make
any sense of me we've also obviously got
an or in our language but we have to
abstract away from those because we're
trying to work with them formally and we
don't want their traditional properties
to be you know to be in there right as a
temporary solution we could have a
context called formal and we put all
these symbols there temporarily until I
know better solution which and they are
protected all the symbols that are the
default operators constants why would we
want to do that I mean why not have a
wrapper with strings because then it's
much easier to deal with them in these
associations where we can just in a
shorthand we can just look like an
axiomatic theory thing we're not saying
formal blah blah blah of multiplication
goes to this
we're just saying multiplication goes to
that yeah it's because we have to
introduce if we have to deduce a system
symbol and we are not sure about the
name no I understand I I don't think
look I think um what do you feel what do
you think about axiomatic constant or
for that matter axiomatic symbol I mean
it gives some conceptual
contextualization that this is about
axiom systems and I would argue okay so
axiomatic symbol for example
um it's really a good question to ask
Dennis Scott he might have an immediate
and sensible answer um or he might tell
us that it's all unbelievably
complicated and it's impossible we do
whatever we thought we're gonna do go
ahead symbol is being used in the
context of an axiomatic theory but the
symbol itself is not axiomatic
necessarily no I understand that
yes but but what is the symbol the
symbol is in some sense it is what would
usually be called formal it is merely a
placeholder it is something that has a
role in an axiomatic system but I mean
in in some sense it is axiomatic because
okay there's a view of the world which
is in terms of axioms you know there's
one view of the world which is just
there are numbers 1 2 3 and they have
certain arithmetic properties and we can
compute with them
there's another view of the world which
just says we don't even say what a
number is we just have this formal thing
and it Bay's certain axioms great and
what this is saying is this is in the
view of the world well what is this this
is sort of an intermediate case because
this is a view of the world where the
structure is predefined but the meaning
is not right so in the case of a number
in the case of a 1 2 3 type integer both
the structure and the meaning are
predefined we think there's a sort of
ground truth meaning to them in the case
of axiom systems we have the slightly
hybrid case which perhaps is not even
right that the structure is defined like
we say these are binary operators we
I've never known of any axiom system
that says is an operator we don't say
whether it's a binary operator or
ternary operator or anything else right
I mean actually schemas go a little bit
of the way towards this but not all the
way but so then we're saying so we're
not just saying it's an operator we're
not going to say what kind of operator
we are we are choosing something
definite with respect to structure is
the thing we don't do that we you know
we can say nothing basically right
so it's sort of a weird intermediate
case axiom system but I hadn't really
thought of it that way before but they
are a weird intermediate case so the
question is what are those carriers of
essentially axiomatic structure
that are yeah how does that how do we
think about that I mean if we go in this
direction shouldn't we they're not kind
of use model theory and related stuff
then what well yes these things we are
defining effectively models were not
quite in 30 yo it's we're defining a
model but without really without any
semantics yes it hasn't gotten all the
way to model theory it's kind of I don't
know whether the model theorists have a
name for this stage so to speak I mean
they nobody talks about to my knowledge
an axiom system without you know without
form so to speak you know the void axiom
system so to speak without you know um
people always say it has binary
operators etcetera etcetera etcetera I
mean it's fairly similar to talking
about you know when you start talking
about computation and then pretty soon
you're talking about Turing machines or
cellular automata they have structure um
pump we need a name to this I personally
I am not horrified by something like you
know either axiomatic symbol I'm not
horrified by the name axiomatic symbol
even though it's kind of weird but this
is a weird thing I mean this is a symbol
whose character is defined merely by the
constraints of axioms we could call it
axiom symbol an invaluable resource or
used frequently in this context except
that they aren't variables they're
they're not that the whole point of them
is they're not variable I mean the
notion of but the notion of the head of
the operator you know the thing that's
going to represent a multiplication or
an and or an or that's not um what about
axiom symbol it loses the immediate
connection with axiomatic theory that's
true okay
look I'm I'm my current thinking as
axiomatic symbol it's a little weird I
mean
what that what would you think that
meant a symbol that is defined
axiomatically which I yeah as much as
what it is right yeah exactly
on the other hand when you hear
axiomatic you kind of think it's it's
tethered somewhere and this symbol is
very untethered in a sense it doesn't
have a meaning it just has something
which is defined by an axiom system all
right look I'm thinking axiomatic symbol
and I'm thinking we've got a proto
design here which is actually quite good
and that Jonathan should try and quickly
you know mock it up and put his data
into it and see how it works how could
you do that okay we should wrap this
meeting because we're super late okay
and I should say back those pages and we
are only we are not quite finished with
the knitting for guide pages and so on
um okay and I guess I'll see you guys in
due course and for anybody on the
livestream that's it for this episode